HUMAN SMUGGLING.
LAURA, WE'LL SEND IT BACK TO YOU
>> LAURA: UNBELIEVABLE STORY.
NOW, WHILE OUR BORDER COMPLETELY
BREAKS DOWN, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION HAS SET ITS
SIGHTS ELSEWHERE.
SO CALLED AMERICAN
INFRASTRUCTURE, BUT NOT BY
ADDRESSING THE VERY REAL ISSUE
OF ROADS AND BRIDGES, BUT RATHER
BY POURING BILLIONS INTO
POLITICAL PET PRONG THAT HE CAN
COULD FUNDAMENTALLY CHANGE THE
FACE OF THIS COUNTRY.
NOW, EARLIER TONIGHT, MAJORITY
LEADER CHUCK SCHUMER DECIDE
ASKED TO MOVE TOWARD A FINAL
VOTE ON THE BILL DESPITE THE
FACT THAT IT HASN'T EVEN BEEN
WRITTEN YET.
HERE NOW SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM.
SENATOR THE MEDIA STILL CALLING
THIS EFFORT, QUOTE, BIPARTISAN.
HOW IS THIS BIPARTISAN AND WHY
WOULD A SINGLE REPUBLICAN, EVEN
IF YOU'RE RETIRING, GRANT THEM
THE VENEER OF LEGITIMACY HERE?
>> RIGHT.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO FILE -- WE'RE
NOT GOING TO PROCEED TO A BILL
THAT'S NOT WRITTEN BECAUSE THAT
MAKES NO SENSE.
SO IF JOE BIDEN REALLY WANTS TO
DO INFRASTRUCTURE, ROADS,
BRIDGES AND PORTS FOR AROUND A
TRILLION DOLLARS, THERE ARE
PLENTY OF REPUBLICANS THAT WOULD
AND CHUCK SCHUMER'S TRYING TO
LOAD THIS EFFORT UP.
CAN YOU IMAGINE?
YOU'VE BEEN AROUND TOWN FOR A
WHILE LAURA.
FILING CLOSER ON A BILL THAT
DOESN'T EXIST IS INSANE.
SO PRESIDENT BIDEN, GET ON THE
PHONE TO SCHUMER AND SELL HIM TO
STAND DOWN.
TELL HIM THAT YOU'RE
UNDERCUTTING AN EFFORT TO FIND
COMMON GROUND ON INFRASTRUCTURE
REGARDING ROADS, BRIDGES AND
PORTS.
YOU CAN TELL SCHUMER TO STOP.
WHETHER HE WILL OR NOT I DON'T
KNOW.
BUT YOU SHOULD AT LEAST TRY TO
STOP HIM FROM BLOWING THIS UP.
>> WELL, AMY KLOBUCHAR KIND OF
GAVE AWAY THE GAME.
WATCH.
>> WHAT YOU CAN DO FROM
INFRASTRUCTURE, WHICH IS NOT IN
THE BIPARTISAN PACKAGE AND I'M
GLAD THEY'RE CONTINUING TO
NEGOTIATE AND MAKE PROGRESS.
WHAT YOU CAN DO IS PUT ELECTION
INFRASTRUCTURE IN THERE.
YOU COULD TIE IT TO CERTAIN
THINGS AS INCENTIVES FOR STATES
TO DO SAME-DAY REGISTRATION, TO
DO THE MAIL-IN BALLOTING.
>> LAURA: OKAY.
MAIL-IN BALLOTS.
THAT'S PART OF INFRASTRUCTURE.
WHAT?
>> WITH ROADS AND BRIDGES.
YEAH.
SO THIS IS THE POWER GRIP.
THE THREE AND A HALF TRILLION
DOLLARS DEMOCRATIC
INFRASTRUCTURE PACKAGE HAS GOT
NOT A DAM THING TO DO WITH
INFRASTRUCTURE.
THEY'RE WANTING TO PUT AMNESTY
INTO THE INFRASTRUCTURE BILL.
SO YOU HAD A GREAT STORY JUST A
MOMENT AGO ABOUT A BROKEN
BORDER.
IMAGINE IF YOU GAVE LEGAL STATUS
TO ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS WITHOUT
FIRST SECURING THE BORDER.
NO PROPOSAL THAT'S EVER BEEN
MADE IN WASHINGTON GAVE LEGAL
STATUS UNTIL THE BORDER WAS
FIRST SECURED.
JOE BIDEN SAID TODAY HE WANTS TO
PUT AMNESTY IN THE DEMOCRATIC
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL, THAT WILL
LEAD TO AN INVASION OF ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION, IT WILL PUT JET
FUEL ON A SYSTEM THAT'S ALREADY
BROKEN.
IF YOU GIVE ONE PERSON LEGAL
STATUS, THERE WILL BE A RUN ON
OUR BORDER LIKE YOU'VE NEVER
SEEN BEFORE.
THE DUMBEST IDEA IN THE HISTORY
OF THE SENATE, THE HISTORY OF
THE WHITE HOUSE.
IT WILL LEAD TO A BREAKDOWN OF
LAW AND ORDER BEYOND WHAT YOU
SEE TODAY.
>> LAURA: WELL, THE PRESIDENT IS
SAYING THAT THESE INVESTMENTS,
SENATOR GRAHAM, ARE GOING TO
HELP WITH INFLATION.
WATCH.
>> THEY ARE.
>> WE MAKE PRUDENT MULTI YEAR
INVESTMENTS, IT BREAKS UP THE
BOTTLE NEXT IN OUR ECONOMY.
GOODS GET TO CONSUMERS MORE
RAPIDLY AND LESS EXPENSEIVELY.
IT WILL TAKE THE PRESSURE OFF OF
INFLATION, GIVE A BOOST TO OUR
WORK FORCE WHICH LEADS TO LOWER
PRICES IN THE YEARS AHEAD.
SO, IF YOUR PRIMARY CONCERN
RIGHT NOW IS INFLATION, YOU
SHOULD BE EVEN MORE ENTHUSIASTIC
ABOUT THIS PLAN.
>> OKAY, NOW, SENATOR, TALK
ABOUT DISINFORMATION CAMPAIGNS.
HOW DOES MASSIVE SPENDING THAT
WE OBVIOUSLY DON'T NEED ON ALL
THIS OTHER EXTRANEOUS STUFF, HOW
DOES THAT NOT SPUR MORE
INFLATION?
HOW IS THIS, IN ANY WAY,
SOMETHING THAT SENATOR PORTER
WOULD EVER SIGN ONTO OR MANSION,
FOR THAT MATTER.
HE'S YOUR BUDDY.
WHAT IN GOD'S NAME IS GOING ON
HERE?
>> RIGHT.
SO WHEN WILL YOU UNDERSTAND, AND
I DON'T MEAN YOU, PERSONALLY,
BUT THE COUNTRY THAT FOR US
BIDEN'S A NICE FELLOW WHO
DOESN'T KNOW WHAT HE'S DOING.
LOOK AT THE BORDER.
IT WAS SECURE.
THE LOWEST ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT
CROSSINGS IN DECEMBER 2020 WHAT
TRUMP DID WORKS.
SIX MONTHS LATER A MILLION
PEOPLE ACROSS THE BORDER AND
HEADED TO TWO.
THE VICE-PRESIDENT WENT TO THE
BORDER, WHAT DID SHE LEARN?
WHAT HAS SHE DONE?
SHE VISITED THE BORDER AT HE
WORSE NOW.
THERE'S NO PLAN TO SECURE THE
BORDER.
IF YOU THINK MANDATING PAID
FAMILY LEAVE ON EVER EMPLOYER ON
THE COUNTRY IS GOING TO LOWER
PRICES, YOU'RE CRAZY.
THIS BILL IS GOING TO BE A
MASSIVE TAX INCREASE ON BUSINESS
AND IT'S GOING TO EXPAND THE
SIZE AND ROLE OF GOVERNMENT, NOT
ROADS, BRIDGES AND PORTS.
IT'S GOING TO LEAD TO HIGHER
PRICES AND LESS JOBS AND HIGHER
TAXES.
IT'S JUST LIKE THE BORDER.
THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY'RE
DOING
>> LAURA: I DISAGREE WITH YOU,
THEY KNOW EXACTLY WHAT THEY'RE
DOING.
OKAY.
>> YOU MAY BE RIGHT.
YOU MAY BE RIGHT
>> Jim: THIS IS PURPOSEFUL.
THEY'RE NOT MORONS.
THEY SEE WE HAVE A MILLION PLUS
PEOPLE ALREADY HERE AND THEY'RE
NOT DOING A DAM -- THEY'RE JUST
OPENING THE GATES, WE OPENED THE
GATES FOR PEOPLE ALL OVER THE
WORLD TODAY.
>> I'M NOT TAKING THE MORE ON
THING OFF THE TABLE.
WHAT I WILL SAY IS IT'S THE
WORST I'VE EVER SEEN IT LAURA
AND GETTING WORSE EVERY DAY
>> LAURA: SENATOR I HOPE SANITY
PREVAILS IN THIS INFRASTRUCTUR